[Music]  you are  like  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  we know he's dead but we didn't kill him  you like to murder or whatever mr. ron  ron Litani  the girl seems actually Leilani because  we have nothing to hide officer we just  need to find the guy but police are  looking for you suggesting we actually  go out there and follow up murder black  did you think it was one of those men  only doors and then we're in the pier  hey man it's been a minute who do you  work for you little [ __ ] you don't bean  bag ball this [ __ ] yeah do you think on  your grandma on that for a bean bag  [ __ ] what these people are super  dangerous and they're really powerful  their system Handmaid's Tale [ __ ]  we have imposters oh no imposters that  sucks  everyone unmask yourself oh sure nobody  else took that mask  I'm gonna give you lovebirds a choice  what's behind this door or bacon grease  to the fight I don't want grease on my  bias is it gonna [ __ ] on me  [Music]